Ashley Graham may be comfortable in her
own skin
I know I'm sick I know I'm curvy but she
still got emotional while coaching a
group of women for their first lingerie
photo shoot there's an emotion just
rushing through me because sorry things
are changing people are really just
accepting curves the body confident
supermodel teamed up with glamour to
direct a fun afife photo shoot with four
ladies from all shapes and sizes zero
okay okay while reviewing the photos the
women opened up to Ashley about their
insecurities one shared her battle with
skin issues and another confessed she
struggled with an eating disorder
Ashley broke down into tears after
seeing how great the images turned out
as I'm thinking about all the young
girls out there that are so insecure
with their bodies and they're looking
and she do like doing so thank you he
won't just think that body image and the
body revolution is a trend and a fad you
guys it's not it goes from big girls to
little girls it goes from Spanish girls
to black girls it goes from white girls
to young girls
it's it's everybody in between and if we
keep having this conversation if we keep
talking about the things that society
has said are ugly or the things that we
don't see media that is what is gonna
change
[Music]